Arrived being gay and be here in bill includes a supposed. Part of the reason for me coming here would food.
Probably be my sexuality. In there.
At the time living in queensland in his truck sure which still had these accepted homosexuality. It was restrictive.
I guess i felt that. I couldn't see why that should be any why i had to go through all that bullshit. Then coming here.
And still i suppose in this sort of that you do have to be careful that sense of you know survival thing only.
You know if you care if you taste of what around. Before you jump in but then thinking oh fuck you know.
These are all people who have finding out that. You know they died who is.
You know that i should tell you we're all so different in each individual elegy and and.
You look at other people you see. You know. He's taking a selfie. Are you.
That person is really preside of that for this is really.
So weird eccentric and if he can hit us away they are the law. Why can't i just bring the myself there.
And bring that i speak to me. And so then sort of i suppose where you know. You can.
You can go overboard in these things you can sort of. You know sort of guys i will and i'm a guy.
And all of a poster you know and that's it except there are.
No without having to do that but it is interacting with people and then finding that. You know.
People find out what you're all about that either they accept it or they done it if they did all this. You know.
That's a problem and. They're not worse now i the. Finding actually finding. In the ten years of.
Being here i've never had anyone put me down for my sexuality. To my face. That is.
I suppose over all the people to see. Except me for the way. Down for other things.
Being the treasure of trying to create your own body during their money. You fuckwit. Not for my sexuality.
If anything. Quite the opposite that some people really like to key into the. That they like that.
And they like you for your other aspects you know. The. I think people basically like people.
If if if they feel comfortable with you you know if they. They feel you're ok.
And you know they are who don't want to do anything you know sort of. Bad against a motive. Also that.
You know i think people key into your energies if you.
If you sort of stabling itself if you can change within yourself that. That shows that they can.
And i think part of that stability. Is being honest with the self. Just expressing yourself issue.
So that you know what enhances the other. And that overrides all those of the negative aspects.
And yeah it's funny that people just accept that. I do find it.
Especially when with the guys around here the mouse that there are there is sort of probably tolerance.
In some people rather than acceptance of. What it would have or might be that the interact you know. Sure you know.
You do things but. There is a limitation as to how close you can get to.
But there are a lot of guys around who are john mind getting closer to him and doesn't want. Him. Which is great.
I was just talking about guys because you know. They being mile and. I think my liberation has yet to cow.
Because it is well overdue. They really need. Even here in the old to a dish. And actually being gay here.
It's not been a problem. The only thing lately on fining is probably now because.
I possibly feel a need to get back into a relationship. And for that to happen when you're in a village that. You know.
Still at present has very minimal contact with the outside world.
So it's a difficult thing to do i think it's the sort of place that.
If you want to settle down or with a relationship or in a relationship here.
That you need to find a relationship think come here. Rather than finding it here.
Since expressing that to a lot of people i found that people say although you know i i've got a brother who's got a
well my son is gay and stuff like that that. Maybe that's not the case. Yes. But anyway. I mean.
I just i don't think it may have i think at the time.
A number of us here were going through a sort of change period and. Maybe even though it's.
This is a very beautiful place to live in i mean it's fantastic again.
If you've ever been around the world over to parts of the world.
To other countries you know has to realize that we live in utopia. Here is free in place.
But also i think the realization that. One shoelace or in something for a period of time you take it for granted.
And even though you're not environment.
That's brilliant after a while you take it for granted and you possibly need to change your knees.
But that positive negative thing. You know you. You can't always know.
Being happy is unless you experience the opposite. And so you need a change you need to get away. And then.
Sometimes you need an overpowered with politics. Life and politics in everything. Should have way forever.
And that can make you unhappy say things. I don't want to use only this anymore i want to get out of here.
So i want to do something else i need to break away i need to kid. Different stimulation. And then through.
I don't know if there is can stances i think. I actually think we create it even if we don't realize it. Doing a radio.
A course in radio programming and from. The. I got involved.
After that stage was sort of a united sort of a bit of a change going on
and i started i got involved with doing a cool rodeo programming and that was through tafe and list.
And part of that was actually doing. Experience at the un and see. If in the community radio.
Which was then at the college. The northern rivers college at that particular time. And you're ensuring that cause.
We're talking with the program manager. At the station and. She asked me what sort of program. I was looking at doing.
And at the time i thought well. Suppose if i want to do a program be something to do with.
Some something a bit radical gay people or something like that i get a program. And then sometime after that.
She then approach me about.
Actually doing the program there was a gay program called guy ways a gay and lesbian program i should say.
Colgate waste. And she asked me if i get involved with that program and. I thought about it and i thought oh yeah ok.
And sort of circumstance that the times. Create a tad too i suppose.
Sort of coming back receive me and getting stuck and lose more because we had a flood on a particular time
and staying at the radio station to help them.
Because they had to move to equipment and thing finding i was doing it on a programming for the first time.
And then when i started getting involved with the actual gay ways program. And at that particular time.
Sort of finding that it really need to be straight restructured. To create a bit of progress. On the sexual people and.
Approaching a friend and asking her if she would get involved. And she agreed and. Through that. Enfoldment and.
She was actually the one that expressed that she liked to have.
Dances around the area because there really wasn't anybody with that kind of sexual people who go to to meet.
And so i korea and then the realisation that we needed a group of people to set the dance out. So i think the i do you.
Will we need a gay group. And even though there had been various groups and.
Such a kelly guy and i think along was the north america's gay group. And. The other was sunland. Some. Career.
But they really didn't last long and sort of died down. So they went about trying to to form a group.
It was a lot of work for a lot of running around. A lot of structuring that. Very positive stuff. Getting.
I was finding actually i was getting back a lot of very positive feedback and. Coding treat me. Because also.
Some people had expressed that wouldn't happen that there's too much to be around still and especially in these more.
Particular newspaper in these small. At that particular time was very anti gay because their article.
But not really key into that
and i couldn't really see that i suppose because being ability would tend to be somewhat isolated from the system.
And you can get.
So locked up in the place where you're living that you know every now
and then you realize oh well there's a system out there it is. There's a whole new world out there. So not really.
I suppose being keyed into what was happening in the area. And i think that was probably a good thing.
So we went ahead and. The first dance we had actually the majority of people that helped this.
Set up the dance who had her sexual. Friends. It was intriguing and. The dance was a success.
We had about one hundred twenty hundred thirty paying people going in and then it started from there.
Jesus would have been. Three and probably four yeas ago now. Before we. Did the group well at the time. I think it was.
We used the name. Some of the.
Gay krupa then it was until about a third or fourth meeting that we decided on a name which was the tropical fruits.
And. Even for the first i think probably. Seven i know i need ngs we had. There's any handful of those at the meeting.
And the second. We put on we had problems. Were actually experience i think what was a bit of hunger phobia.
Were told at particular the whole will using the last minute we couldn't use because.
The line was going to end and it was then a day before the dance was on. So we had to.
Five find another hole quickly which we did quite fortunately. Didn't find people to sit up to redirect.
People to the new hole. And in spite of all that. That was a second day we had it went off really well.
Was a great day. And. Then i think we had a bit of a lull in the group at that particular time. And.
Farnie by there in that i was doing the gay ways program.
And then we had this group and when you started putting out a newsletter as well.
So joining cordel caught a lot of different things and.
Also at that particular time i got involved a relationship that. Turned out to be quite possess.
I think that was taking my time than anything else. And so i tend to let it go the group a bit.
But unfortunately there were other people there to take over to get involved and that's
when i think it really started taking oath.
Which i suppose shows me that i think you can take a thing so far and then you could let it go and if if it's.
It's meant to happen it'll go. And if it doesn't. There was virtually none.
At that particular time then and only for the gateways program. That was going. And then used to wonder as to.
You know who was if there was in your listening to the program because it was fairly late
and i saw a lot of people be restricted. As to listening to to the program. Because that the the times law.
And there were. We had problems that used to be an earlier time slot pickle moot and we couldn't get it changed bank.
And we wondered with a part of that monitoring for fear hunger phobia again.
But apart from that there was there was no other known network there is an overall net gain network cool. I think.
Country network. That covers the whole of australia. I think there were quite a few people gay people or sexual people.
From this area who were members of that network. But apart from that there was nothing else here.
And there with the group. Police. We had a magazine which was called fruit juice and.
We try and they were used to print out every month.
And then we started linking out with with other groups from other areas and.
Through the gay media and the gay priests were ever ties and yes. Yes. And of course. Now.
I think we're we have a reputation for that particular to get a crew to tropical fruits.
Has a reputation of being the nice day. Country. Network. And the.
Dances well i suppose you could anything up to three hundred people. At a dance which is quite a lot. The reputations.
That dance this is a very crude. Exit. Just getting back to the to the network around the area.
A lot of things seem to happen at the same time with doing the right. Program in the group and then used later and.
And the dances and that. Also got involved with looking at setting out. The network for people for hiv positive people.
That there were a group of people and lose all. They were interested in having meetings and.
At that particular time having meetings at some vincent's hospital. To set up a. I don't know. So i wish for a.
Support crew here for people who had tried for a speaker. And i sort of. Was involved with that food.
To a minimal degree mainly because of my link with with the group as a social group. And the radio program.
What actually happened. Was a call and was approached in sydney and.
They had a person come up to look at setting up a branch up here. And that's what eventually happens. Then we had.
The a comprehension you sell. An old and rivers here you know the district. I'm not exactly sure now on the.
Days but probably that would have been. Maybe just go to three. And to. Fairly well established.
I think they do a lot of good work around here is also there was the needle exchange program. But that was actually.
Set up by the health department i think before a con. And then.
I think a con also has sort of given a lot of help sort of set up a networking system as well and sort of.
Supported by. The the. Tropical fruits and. Even those that.
The tropical fruit is actually just a social group i'm right from the beginning it was expressed that it should just be
purely for enjoyment and in taman it shouldn't be political. Anyway though it's always harder to breathe.
Color ticks into anything. There were there was or used to have a we have. Dances actually.
A lot of the dances recruit paintings create cool. And then there is for a lot of.
We had no problems with that until they had a change in the whole committee.
And then you committee decided it then it would have put just having dances say that.
That letter ended up in a consultation a lot of the meetings and forgotten.
I'm pretty sure in the setting up of the gay group and.
The social group and the radio program and the news let the magazine. We also were approached by.
I think it was fred miller at the time who was. Who's involved with the police and gailey his group. And.
So he came up from sydney and we had meetings with him and one of the local pubs in lewis well.
And also the local community police officer and. I said let's. It way we. We had meetings in.
One of the social venues in lismore. And. Formed also formed the police and a liaison group for this area. And.
Also at the time. There's some people who who felt that we should have. Radical gay groups write. Gay activists and.
Maybe a branch of act up. Should be represented here. And i sort of got involved with that also.
And so we had to make sure that we that we didn't think involved the social group with that. And they were.
There was a time when. Fred nile. Came up. And we. We had a bit of a demonstration at proms with cade's.
Which was televised. So it's quite interesting. What was more interesting was the reaction from people.
I walking down the street people would come up to me that i'd never seen before and say ah so you're on t.v.
and I think.
They say ah it's great i think it's good i like what you're doing i'm really support you
and stuff like that so it's very positive stuff. I was going to. I was a bit of a blower. But that was happening. Was.
Yes there is. And there is so in lismore too apparently i was unaware of it until fairly.
Until after i actually got involved with with helping set up.
The gay groups a social a group that i discovered there was. But. Apart from allowed to help.
Are there were little things like in. I think in some of the local papers like the northern star in the air.
There were articles by people who felt that.
You know having radical pushed his running around the hills is not a good thing.
And that they found that they didn't like it.
And it caused this something like that would happen with a little who'd always be a few of us are gradually cause him.
And replied to that and. Explain that you know pre-human we're people too and.
You know we just want to be ourselves that we're not really hurting anyone. And why should it worries a lot richer.
And i do have a few present a funny story about.